>>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW
EVERYONE.
HAPPY NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP DAY.
SHOUTOUT TO BOWLING AND BRYSON.
I HAVE MY GUYS HERE TODAY.
WE ARE HERE TO BUILD A PARLAY
FOR THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
THAT INCLUDES YOU TOO.
WE ARE GOING TO HELP DECIDE WHAT
WE WILL BE BETTING ON.
I HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST.
THE MAN FOR THE RECORD WITH THE
LARGEST PAY OUT IN SPORTS
BETTING HISTORY AND HAPPENS TO
HAVE $9 MILLION RIDING ON TCU.
HE NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION.
I HAVE THE ONE AND ONLY MATTRESS
MAC.
HOW IS IT GOING?
>> EVERYTHING IS GOOD NATALIE.
FEELING GOOD.
FEELING LUCKY.
GO FROGS.
>> WELCOME TO THE SHOW AND
THANKS FOR COMING BY.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT YOUR
TCU BET.
MOST OF IT IS ON THE MONEYLINE.
>> I THINK THE FROGS ARE A TEAM
OF DESTINY.
I AM A HUGE FROG FAN.
THEY REALLY GOT IT GOING.
I THINK THEY ARE THE TEAM OF
DESTINY.
BIGGEST UPSET IN SPORTS HISTORY
MAY BE COMING UP TONIGHT.
>> WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE
TO SAY.
LET'S GET TO THE QUESTION ON
EVERYONE'S MIND.
WE KNOW YOU ARE CONFIDENT IN
TCU.
$9 MILLION ON THE LINE.
IF TCU GOES UP EARLY, WOULD YOU
HEDGE?
>> I NEVER HEDGE.
THEY WERE WANTING ME TO HEDGE
THE ASTROS BET.
NO WAY.
>> WE LOVE TO HEAR THAT, NEVER
HEDGE.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MAC COMING UP.
I WILL ASK YOU THIS IN THE
MEANTIME.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN TO TEXANS.
200-1 PRESEASON.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN TO THE
PEOPLE?
>> IT WOULD BE GREAT.
A TEXAS TEAM NEVER WON THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE NEW
FORMAT.
THE LAST WAS TEXAS IN 2005.
ALL TEXANS ARE PULLING FOR TCU
AND WE THINK TONIGHT WILL BE A
BIG NIGHT FOR THE FROGS OUT IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> WE HAVE THE FROGS UP.
WHAT DOES THE CHAT HAVE TO SAY?
WHAT YOU GOT?
THERE IS LOVE IN THE CHAT.
TCU MONEY LINE FOR THE WIN.
THE PADRES FAN SAYING WE LOVE
YOU MAC.
I AM A MICHIGAN FAN, BUT I AM
BACKING YOU TONIGHT, MAC.
LET'S GET IT DONE.
>> MAC, I KNOW SOME PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW THIS.
YOU AND I WERE IN VEGAS AT 3:00
A.M. PLACING $1 MILLION BETS AT
THE BELLAGIO.
I WANT YOUR WORDS OF WISDOM OR
SUPPORT ON THE BET THAT I HAVE.
MAX DUGGAN TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
PLUS 120.
EASIEST BET IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE HITTING THIS, RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I LOVE MAX DUGGAN.
I THINK HE IS THE KEY TO THE
GAME, HIM SCORING THE FIRST
TOUCHDOWN ALL FOR IT.
>> I THINK MAX DUGGAN, FIRST TD
IS GOOD VALUE.
WE MIGHT HAVE TO SNEAK THAT IN
THE PARLAY.
>> THAT IS A SPRINKLE SITUATION.
SECOND ONE, AND BEAR WITH ME FOR
A SECOND.
TCU TO CALL THE FIRST TIME-OUT.
MINUS 120.
IT IS A SITUATION, GEORGIA
HASN'T CALLED THE FIRST TIME-OUT
IN THREE MONTHS.
TCU, COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYOFF
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
FEELS LIKE A FIRST TIME-OUT
SITUATION.
>> I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT ONE.
TCU SCORING THE FIRST TOUCHDOWN
IS WHERE I WOULD BE AT.
>> WAIT FOR THE SUPER BOWL FOR
THE CRAZY ONES LIKE THE GATORADE
COLOR.
ALL-IN ON THE FROGS.
ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE CHAT
BEFORE WE SEND MAC OFF AND BRING
HIM BACK?
>> I GOT A FUN COMMENT SAYING HE
BOUGHT A MATTRESS YESTERDAY.
GO TCU.
WE HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORTERS FOR
YOU.
MAX DUGGAN.
MAC IS THE MAN.
G
GANGSTA MAC.
THE APP COMMUNITY IS DEFINITELY
IN FAVOR OF YOU TONIGHT.
>> WE LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
>> MY SON'S IDEA TO HAVE ME PUT
ON THE MINK COAT, HAT AND CHAIN
AND GET IN THAT PURPLE
LAMBORGHINI.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR TALKING TO
US.
TCU'S COLOR ARE PURPLE.
IF TCU WINS HOW ABOUT CARRYING
PURPLE MATTRESSES AT GALLERY
FURNITURE.
>> IF TCU WINS WE WILL CONSIDER
THE PURPLE MATTRESSES WHILE I AM
SELLING THOSE TEMPUR PEDIC
MATTRESSES.
>> MAC, WE ARE GO TO BRING YOU
BACK IN A FEW MINUTES.
SEE YOU IN A FEW.
I AM REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT.
I KIND OF WANT A PURPLE
MATTRESS.
FOR EVERYBODY OUT THERE IN THE
CHAT, AS PROMISED, WE ARE GOING
THREE LEGS.
IS THAT THE PLAN?
>> YEAH.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE
ARE DOING THIS.
A LOT OF HIGH ACTIVITY AND HIGH
STAR PLAYERS IN THE GAME.
WE CAN PUT TOGETHER A
THREE-LEGLOCK.
>> I AM LOOKING AT THE CHAT NOW.
I AM WAITING TO SEE ANYTHING
THAT THE PEOPLE WANT IN OUR
PARLAY.
I AM WITH YOU ON THAT BOWLING.
IS THERE ANYONE WITH US ON
DUGGAN, ANY TIME TD?
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE A GOOD
PLACE TO START BRYSON.
>> YES.
IT DOES NOT MATTER WHO YOU THINK
IS GOING TO WIN THE GAME.
ALL THAT YOU NEED TO KNOW IS
THAT MAX DUGGAN IS FINDING A WAY
TO CROSS THE LINE.
THROUGH THE AIR, WITH HIS FEET,
DIVING, SOMERSAULT, WHATEVER IT
IS.
THAT IS THE EASIEST BET OF THE
NIGHT.
>> I LIKE THE BET.
PART OF ME IS WONDERING IF HE IS
BEAT UP AT ALL.
HE USES HIS BODY SO MUCH AND
THROWS HIMSELF AROUND THAT I AM
A LITTLE BIT WORRIED.
>> HIS GAME IN THE BIG 12
CHAMPIONSHIP WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
AND THEN HE TOOK A BEATING IN
THAT MICHIGAN GAME.
HE IS JUST A GAMER.
HE AIN'T GOING TO FEEL ANY OF IT
ONCE THEY KICK THE BALL OFF.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
MAX DUGGAN TD.
I AM GUESSING THEY ARE GOING ANY
TIME.
MAC SAID DUGGAN FIRST TD.
>> THAT IS WHY I HAVE A LOSING
RECORD.
I AM HERE SEEING TCU TEAM TOTAL
UNDER 23.5.
WE ARE EXPECTING THEY ARE GOING
TO GET AT LEAST CLOSE TO 25.
I THINK THAT IS A GOOD ONE.
>> I WOULD TAKE THAT.
>> NATALIE, YOU AND I WERE AT
THE PEACH BOWL.
THAT GEORGIA DEFENSE COULDN'T
STOP ME OR YOU.
THEY WERE NOT VERY GOOD.
I DON'T SEE ANY WAY THAT TCU'S
OFFENSE -- WORST CASE SCENARIO
THEY GET DESTROYED AND ARE DOWN
30 SCORING USELESS POINTS.
I DO LIKE TCU.
LOVE MATTRESS MAC BUT THERE IS A
LOT OF PRO-TCU STUFF SPAMMED
INTO THE CHAT AND PARLAY AND IT
IS A TEAM LIKE A 13.5 POINT
FAVORITE AND PROBABLY GOING TO
WIN THE GAME TONIGHT.
JUST SAYING.
>> IF I SEE THAT, IS THAT WHAT
YOU WERE GOING TO SAY?
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY THAT.
WE WERE ON THE SAME PAGE.
THERE IS A LOT OF LOVE FOR
GEORGIA.
McINTOSH OVER 65.5 RUSH YARDS.
MAYBE WE LOOK TOWARDS McINTOSH.
>> I SEE JUST STRAIGHT UP GOING
WITH THE OVER.
OVER 63.5 COULD BE THE PLAY.
I DON'T KNOW.
TAKING THE OVER IS NOT A BAD
PLAY.
>> I THINK THE IDEA IS THAT IF
WE DO A PARLAY, WE KNOW MAC HAS
ALL OF THE MONEY ON THE TCU
MONEYLINE AND SPREAD.
WHY DON'T WE LOCK IN THE TEAM
TOTAL AND HOPE FOR A BIG NIGHT
FROM THE HORNED FROGS.
>> THE FIRST BET WE MENTIONED
ALL RIGHT.
COOL.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU SEE IN THE
CHAT?
IT IS SO PRO-TCU.
I AM GETTING CONCERNED.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TROUBLE WITH THE TEAM
TOTAL.
I AM NOT SURE.
MAYBE WE CAN'T PARLAY IT.
THAT IS FINE.
MAX DUGGAN IS A GOOD PLACE FOR
THAT.
>> WE CAN.
I THINK WE CAN.
I THINK WE ARE NOT ON THE XGP
OPTIONS.
I THINK THAT WAS THE PROBLEM WE
HAD.
I MIGHT BE WRONG.
>> EITHER WAY, I LOVE MAX DUGGAN
AND MAYBE IF WE CAN GET SOME
MORE ACTION ON THE TOTAL, MAYBE
IT IS THE GAME TOTAL.
I JUST FEEL LIKE THERE ARE GOING
TO BE A TON OF POINTS.
>> I AM WITH YOU AND I LIKE BOTH
OF THOSE BETS.
SPEAKING OF THE OVER, WE HAVE
BOWERS OVER EVERYTHING.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE WANT TO ADD
UGA SPICE IN HERE.
WE ARE PRETTY PRO-TCU.
WHAT ARE OUR THOUGHTS THERE?
>> BROCK BOWERS IS ONE OF THE
BEST PLAYERS IN THE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T GO WRONG BETTING ON
BROCK BOWERS.
YOU WERE TELLING ME EARLIER.
HE IS A STAR.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE A GREAT GAME
YOU WOULD ASSUME.
IN MY OPINION, FOUR IS BETTER
THAN THREE.
JOHNSTON, 70 PLUS.
BROCK BOWERS, 50 PLUS YARDS.
THAT IS ALL I GOT TO SAY.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT THE CHAT
THINKS OF QUENTIN JOHNSTON.
I MIGHT LIKE THAT FOR BETTER
THAN OVER YARDS.
IS THAT ONE THAT WE CAN ADD IN
HERE?
>> I AGREE BUT WE CAN NOT IN A
SAME GAME PARLAY.
>> HE IS GOING TO GET A LIONS
SHARE OF THE TARGET.
HE IS THEIR GO-TO GUY ON THE
OUTSIDE AND A MATCHUP NIGHTMARE
FOR A LOT OF TEAMS.
WHILE GEORGIA'S DBs ARE NOT
GREAT THEY ARE BIG, TALL, FAST
AND PHYSICAL.
THEY COULD PRESENT DEFENSIVE
PUSH-BACK THAT I DO NOT KNOW HE
HAS SEEN.
EITHER WAY HE WILL GET HIS
THOUGH.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
>> I AGREE.
SOMEONE ELSE SAID McINTOSH,
BOWERS OVER 50 RECEIVING YARDS.
OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE BACK IN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE GOT IT.
WE ARE ON DUGGAN.
WE ARE ALIGNED THERE.
DO WE WANT THAT DOWN A LITTLE?
>> I THINK 23.5 IS THE RIGHT
SPOT TO GET.
BACK TO TEAM SCORING.
SCROLL DOWN.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE WE GO.
>> I LIKE TEASING IT DOWN.
I THINK THAT IS SMART.
>> YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
NUMBERS.
24.5 PUTS YOU IN A HOLE AT THE
END.
IT WOULD BE EASIER TO GET 24
OBVIOUSLY THAN 25 WHEN YOU THINK
OF KICKING FIELD GOALS AND ALL
THAT.
>> DELETE MAX DUGGAN.
YOU NEED TO RESELECT MAX DUGGAN.
AT LEAST THE CHAT IS NOT
CONFUSED THAT WE ARE PUTTING IT
TOGETHER.
WE HAVE THE MAGIC PRODUCER
OBVIOUSLY STRUGGLING BUT WE LOVE
HIM ANYWAY.
>> DON'T GET MAD AT US.
>> WHY ARE Y'ALL BETTING ON THE
QB TO SCORE.
FACE PALM.
THAT DUDE IS A HAMMER ON THE
GOAL LINE.
DO WE LISTEN OR FEEL LIKE WE
NEED TO MAKE A CHANGE?
>> THE ONE HE DIDN'T, HE DID NOT
NEED TO.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD LOOK FOR
THE LAST LEG.
I WANT TO REVISIT, QUENTIN
JOHNSON.
SEEMS LIKE TAKING ONE OF HIS
PROPS IS TOO EASY.
I THINK HE COULD BE A GREAT
FINAL LEG IN THE PARLAY AND I
WILL LOOK IN THE CHAT TO SEE IF
ANYBODY IS WITH ME OR NOT.
>> WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE SUPPORT FOR JOHNSON, DUGGAN
RUNS A LOT.
WE DEFINITELY WATCH.
I DO THINK THAT KENNY McINTOSH
IS A LEG WE NEED TO ENTER HERE
SO WE ARE NOT ALL COMPLETELY ON
TCU.
WE SAID IT WAS A THREE LEG.
KENNY McINTOSH.
THEN JOHNSON, 70 PLUS.
>> MAKE IT FOUR LEGS AND MAKE IT
KENNY MAC.
I DO LIKE THE RECEIVING YARDS.
I ALSO LIKE HIS RUSHING YARDS.
>> I REALLY AGREE.
>> ARE WE TURNING IT INTO FOUR
LEGS OR THE FOUR WE ARE GOING
WITH?
>> YEAH.
WE ARE GOING Q.J., RIGHT?
70 PLUS RECEIVING.
>> YEAH.
>> RECEIVING.
>> 70 RECEIVING.
I LIKE IT A LOT.
>> I LIKE IT.
WHAT IS THE FINAL PRICE HERE.
ALL RIGHT GUYS.
>> WE BENNY SAYING HAVING FUN
LOSING MONEY TONIGHT FOLKS.
REALLY INTERESTING.
WE WILL BE ALL HEADING TO THE
CASHIER.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING A RIGHT.
THIS FEELS LIKE IT CAN'T MISS.
I AM COUNTING ON MONEY EARLY.
THIS IS HITTING.
>> I AM CONFIDENT.
CONFIDENCE CHECK BEFORE WE WRAP
IT UP.
THIS ONE HITTING?
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY THE ONE
THAT IS SCARY FOR ME IS MAX
DUGGAN.
I AM NOT SCARED ABOUT IT.
KENNY McINTOSH IS PROBABLY GOING
TO RUN FOR 50 YARDS ON THE FIRST
PLAY.
TWO OR THREE CATCHES AT THE
STICKS AND THEN MOSS SOMEBODY
FROM GEORGIA.
YOU KNOW, GEORGIA'S DEFENSE IS
GOOD.
MARVIN HARRISON WAS UNGUARDABLE
UNTIL HE GOT HURT.
AND LSU'S BACKUP QUARTERBACK.
THE DEFENSE IS OVERRATED.
I WENT TO KANSAS.
WE WOULD PROBABLY BEAT GEORGIA.
ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> WE LET HIM GO ON THE RANT.
THOSE ARE THE FOUR LEGS OF THE
PARLAY.
OVER 23.5 TCU TOTAL.
MAX DUGGAN.
KENNY McINTOSH, OVER 49.5
RUSHING YARDS AND QUENTIN
JOHNSTON OVER 69.5 RECEIVING
YARDS.
THAT IS IT.
SEE YOU GUYS AT THE CASHIER.
YOU WERE IFFY ABOUT THE MAX
DUGGAN BET.
WE ARE ABOUT TO BRING SOMEONE
BACK, MAC IS COMING BACK IN HERE
RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU ARE IN THE AUDIENCE AND
YOU WANT HIM TO GRADE YOUR BET,
DROP IT IN THE CHAT.
WE HAVE THE MAN SITTING BY US.
HE IS GOING TO GRADE YOUR PICK.
FOR THIS ONE WE ARE GOING TO GO
A, B, C, D, F AND IF YOU REALLY
DON'T LIKE IT F MINUS.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD TRAY ON THE
TREND OF MAX DUGGAN.
OVER RUSH YARDS FOR MAX DUGGAN.
I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER IN FRONT
OF ME BUT FOR WHATEVER IT IS HE
IS GOING TO RUSH FOR ALL OF
THOSE YARDS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE OVER?
>> I LOVE MAX DUGGAN.
OVER.
I AGREE WITH THAT ONE.
THAT IS AN A.
>> WE ARE GOING A FOR MAX
DUGGAN, A LOCAL QB.
ANYTHING STICKING OUT IN THE
CHAT?
>> YEAH.
NOBODY IS GIVING ANYTHING I HAVE
SEEN YET ON THE CHAT.
I AM CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR OPINION,
MAC, GOING BACK TO THE RUSHING
TOUCHDOWN FOR MAX DUGGAN.
IN YOUR OPINION HOW DO YOU SEE
MAX DUGGAN'S FIRST TOUCHDOWN
PLAYING OUT?
>> ABOUT A SEVEN-YARD RUN IN THE
RED ZONE AND HE RUNS IT IN.
MAX DUGGAN IS A HUGE FACTOR IN
THE GAME.
BOTH QUARTERBACKS BUT I AM A MAX
DUGGAN FAN.
>> I AM WITH MAC THERE AND
SPRINKLE FIRST TD SCORE.
>> I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION.
HOW DO YOU CHOOSE YOUR BETS?
>> A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE MONEYLINE.
I THOUGHT WHEN THE MONEYLINE
CAME OUT FOR TCU AT PLUS 440.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS WAY INFLATED.
GEORGIA IS A GREAT TEAM AND TCU
IS A NEWCOMER AND THAT MADE ME
DECIDE TO DO THE PROMOTION.
TAKING THE MONEY LINE ON TCU.
A LOT OF LEVERAGE AND A LOT OF
VALUE.
>> VALUE, I LOVE IT.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE ASKING
YOUR OPINION ON THE OVER.
>> I LOVE THE OVER.
IT IS A GREAT DOME STADIUM AND
THAT BOTH TEAMS ARE GOING TO
LIGHT IT UP.
THAT IS THE HISTORY OF TCU.
THEY RUN A FAST OFFENSE AND WILL
SCORE A LOT OF POINTS.
41-37 FROGS.
HOPEFULLY IT WILL COME TRUE.
>> YOU HEARD IT.
>> OVER 23.5 POINTS.
DOES MAC LIKE TCU'S TEAM TOTAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OVER 23.5.
I WISH I WAS IN A LEGAL BETTING
STATE.
I WOULD BE BETTING A LOT OF
THESE PARLAYS MYSELF.
>> THAT IS REALLY FUNNY.
THE AMOUNT THAT YOU BET AND ALL
OF THE GOOD WORK YOU DO, YOU
WOULD THINK THEY MAKE IT LEGAL
JUST BECAUSE OF ME.
>> I WOULD BET TOO MUCH.
I HAVE A LITTLE RESTRAINT ON ME
HAVING TO GO TO LOUISIANA.
>> SOMEBODY SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
THE ASTROS.
MATTRESS MAC, DO YOU ALREADY
HAVE AN ASTROS 2023 WORLD SERIES
FUTURE BET ALREADY?
>> I AM A HUGE ASTROS.
I HAVE BETS COMING UP AFTER I
GET THROUGH THE FOOTBALL BETS.
I WILL BE BETTING HEAVY ON THE
ASTROS TO REPEAT AS WORLD SERIES
CHAMPIONS IN 2023.
GO STROS.
BEEN IN WANT NL AND AMERICAN
LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES 6 OF
THE LAST 7 YEARS.
>> GO STROS FOR MAC AND GO
FROGS.
>> PURPLE TODAY.
>> PURPLE UP.
FROGS ARE UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
MAC.
ALL RIGHT YOU GUYS.
LET'S LOOK AGAIN AT THE PARLAY
AND REVIEW IT.
I HATE TO USE THE WORD LOCK, BUT
IT JUST FEELS LIKE IT HAS TO BE
A LOCK.
>> I HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE
WANT BET IS NOT GOING TO HIT.
LISTEN.
WE ARE USING OUR BRAINS.
WE WATCHED ALL OF THE GAMES THEY
PLAYED OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS AND MONTHS.
MAX DUGGAN FOUND THE END ZONE.
ALL OF THE RECEIVERS ARE GOING
OVER.
THE RUNNING BACKS HAD HELL OF
RUNNING GAMES.
6/1 VALUE.
WE ARE ALL GETTING NEW WATCHES
TOMORROW SOUNDS LIKE.
>> IF I WERE IN A LEGAL BETTING
STATE, I AM PUTTING IN MA C's
SCORE BET AND DUGGAN FIRST TD.
GOOD THING I AM IN HOUSTON,
TEXAS.
LET'S REVIEW REALLY QUICK FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THE CHAT WE HAVE
FOUR LEG PARLAY.
WE COULDN'T HELP OURSELVES.
TCU TEAM TOTAL OVER.
MAX DUGGAN GETTING INTO THE END
ZONE.
McINTOSH OVER 49.5 RUSHING YARDS
AND QUENTIN JOHNSTON OVER 69.5
RECEIVING YARDS.
THAT WILL PAY ABOUT 6/1.
625 ON THE PARLAY.
I REALLY ENJOYED PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER.
NO WAY I AM NOT GOING TO THE
CASHIER.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR JOINING ME.
WE WILL BE HERE WATCHING THE
GAME WITH MAC TONIGHT AND FOLLOW
US IN THE APP AND ON SOCIAL.
UNTIL THEN WE WILL SEE YOU GUYS
NEXT TIME.